Everyone worries about the future now and
then, even members of the O5 Council, the
most powerful figures in the SCP Foundation.
Civilians resort to keeping themselves in
blissful ignorance or relying on the calming
platitudes of horoscopes and fortune cookies,
but the O5 Council has access to considerably
more accurate methods of understanding the
future.
That’s why, when O5-2 began to feel anxious
about the future of the human race, she took
matters into her own hands.
She’d already spent time using SCP-2003
- a device created by the Foundation to travel
briefly into the future - in hopes of seeing
what fate had in store for humanity.
But very few of the futures shown by SCP-2003
were good ones for the human race, with many
showing various end of the world scenarios
playing out.
So instead O5-2 decided to make her way to
Existential Isolation Facility Beta - an experimental
facility that contains an entirely separate
reality - In order to get into contact with
SCP-411.
SCP-411 is a centuries-old man from the future
who ages in reverse.
Though his advanced age has rendered him somewhat
senile, useful facts about the future can
sometimes be noted from his scattered memories
of what is yet to come.
While getting him to part with this information
is a risky procedure - given that 411 is so
old that even extended conversations might
kill him - in times of absolute emergency,
it’s sometimes the clearest look into the
future the Foundation has.
O5-2 hoped that, in talking to SCP-411, she
could settle some of her anxieties regarding
humanity’s future.
But the answers she got from the senile, bed-bound
Ancient Precognitive weren’t exactly what
she was hoping for.
When she asked him whether there was a future
for humanity on earth he responded:
“The Planet of Hands.
This is what we are to speak of.
I am from there, you know.
As are you, child.
You shall know more of it in time.
I am glad to be here now instead.
Greetings, prodigal daughter.
Unlike me, you'll be home soon.”
Unsatisfied, O5-2 left shortly after, her
anxiety undeterred.
Little did she know, she had very good reasons
to be anxious about humanity’s future, and
we’re not just talking about nuclear war
or climate change.
We’re talking about the threat nobody expects:
SCP-001.
And this time, it isn’t the Black Moon,
or the Scarlet King, or the terrifying When
Day Breaks.
Today, we’re talking about...Well, we’ll
get to that in due time.
It’d be a terrible shame to spoil the surprise.
And besides, there’s a lot of chaos and
horror to get through before then.
The Foundation has always been vaguely aware
of SCP-001 and the terrible threat it poses
towards all of humanity, but that doesn’t
necessarily mean they understand its true
nature.
Still, does it matter whether or not a deer
understands the hunter’s rifle?
No - Only that it must avoid being found between
its crosshairs.
And the Foundation’s method for staying
out of 001’s crosshairs was known as SCP-2798.
This Thaumiel-Class anomaly was created by
the Foundation to specifically keep 001 away
from all of us.
Since the start of recorded history, strange
anomalous activity has been reported, causing
suffering and distress against humans.
This eventually led to the creation of The
SCP Foundation, which seemingly correlated
with a massive spike in severe and dangerous
anomalous activity.
All of this activity was believed to lead
back to SCP-001: An anomalous, hostile, and
highly intelligent entity or series of entities
that wish to do humanity great harm.
Rather than playing whack-a-mole with 001’s
anomalies, they hoped to deal with its threat
more directly, leading to the creation of
SCP-2798.
To go into too much detail would probably
derail the video entirely, but for us to give
you a brief summary of what exactly SCP-2798
is: It’s comprised of 8000 melted human
souls as well as several SCPs being pumped
down into the earth’s mantle.
While this came with certain unpleasant side
effects, it also acted as a kind of cloaking
device - By pumping so much life essence into
the earth, it made us all seem like one single
organism, thus keeping the watchful eyes of
SCP-001 away from all of us.
This initiative was given the codename Project
Serapis.
Here’s the problem, though: Project Serapis
was never meant to be a permanent fix.
And what’s more, it’s actually been degrading
over the last several decades, until it finally,
recently collapsed.
Earth’s cloaking device had collapsed with
it, and now, the eyes of SCP-001 were starting
to come into focus on our pale blue dot.
And just like O5-2 had feared, things were
about to get an awful lot worse.
On November 2nd, 2016, 001 detected the population
of earth and began to work its terrifying
magic.
It began creating what is known as Altered
Phenomena out of pre-existing anomalies.
Think of them almost as Super SCPs, almost
universally stronger and more dangerous than
their original incarnations.
If you thought the SCPs were dangerous before,
then these new ones are your worst nightmare.
It didn’t take long for chaos to break out.
A huge number of the Foundation databases
across the globe experienced sudden collapses.
The horrifying monster that SCP-058, the Heart
of Darkness, belonged to, began attacking
its containment area.
Massive containment breaches occurred in a
huge number of sites, and soldiers and containment
experts were dispatched in hopes of bringing
this rapidly escalating situation back under
control.
Photos of SCP-439, the Bone Hive Earwigs,
were somehow leaked on Imgur.
Some constellations even began disappearing
all over the sky.
SCP-1000s launched a violent coup and took
over Blalock, Oregon.
As the global 001 situations escalated and
anomalies began overwhelming different Foundation
strongholds, some sites were considered lost,
though employees were threatened with termination
if they abandoned their posts.
Some anomalies went entirely missing into
the civilian world and started causing chaos.
M. Al-Hamzi, one of the Foundation’s interfaith
liaisons from Armed Area-19, was quoted saying
“The day will come when this earth will
be substituted with a new earth, and also
the heavens, and everyone will be brought
before GOD, the One, the Supreme.
Allah preserve us.”
You’re probably wondering: Given that an
army of enhanced SCPs were released to cause
violence and chaos across the globe by SCP-001,
do we have any specific examples of some of
the anomalies made bigger, badder, and a hell
of a lot more dangerous by this mysterious
foe?
Don’t worry - The rest of this video is
going to be specific examples of exactly that.
Take, for example, SCP-087, the Endless Stairwell.
This went from a localized entity at an undisclosed
university administrative building to an even
more dangerous stairwell in the Pentagon,
which had the ability to open and close its
doorway at will, presumably hoping to capture
some power players from the United States
Department of Defense.
The terrifying SCP-106, also known as the
Old Man, also got a significant power boost.
He became so intelligent that he was capable
of conversing with Foundation staff - Presumably
just to say nasty things to them as they tortured
them to death.
He was also able to better control his dimensional
portal abilities, making escape far easier.
Which is bad news for the human race, given
the Old Man’s dark tendencies.
SCP-294, the coffee machine, got an incredibly
weird upgrade - Now, rather than dispensing
items that can mess with individuals, it messes
with the global economy via the success or
failure of the Coca Cola Company, one of the
largest beverage companies in the world.
Transactions performed on SCP-294 will affect
the global stock price and trading success
for the company, creating wild economic instability.
SCP-662, the Butler’s Hand Bell that summons
the delightfully practical butler Mr. Deeds,
went from convenient to terrifying.
Any time it was rung, the ringer was brought
to a random, unknown location where they would
be asked to perform a seemingly impossible
task, and then be anomalously compelled to
complete said task.
This could lead to debilitating and distressing
injuries.
Now you know how poor Mr. Deeds feels.
SCP-701, the Hanged King’s Tragedy, was
originally a lethal, cursed play that causes
madness and death for anyone unlucky enough
to witness it.
After SCP-001, The Hanged King’s Tragedy
was transformed into a mass-marketed HBO series
starring Javier Bardem
in the title role.
The show was immediately renewed for five
seasons, meaning it will likely cause horrifying
death and madness for millions across the
globe.
SCP-993 was a disturbing anomalous children’s
program hosted by the infamous Bobble The
Clown, who would convince the children in
the audience to commit violent or depraved
acts.
Thanks to the SCP-001 boost, Bobble instead
took up an adult news show on cable television,
where he instead exerted his violent influence
over global power players.
His guests have included then-United Kingdom
Foreign Secretary Boris Johnson, Philippine
President Rodrigo Duterte, Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau, and National People's
Congress of China Chairman Zhang Dejiang.
SCP-1981, also known as "RONALD REAGAN CUT
UP WHILE TALKING", was a cursed VHS tape of
a Ronald Reagan speech that shows the former
president being mutilated and speaking violent
nonsense.
Naturally, thanks to SCP-001, this obscure
little tape got a serious upgrade.
It became a series of massively viewed videos
on the video-sharing platform Dailymotion.
It shows a completely skinned version of Ronald
Reagan, addressing the 2013 meeting of the
World Economic Forum in Davos, Switzerland.
Rather than the typical blood and brimstone,
though, the content of each speech consists
of technical specifications for as-yet-unknown
anomalous technological devices.
SCP-2006, also known as Too Spooky, was a
shapeshifter with the stated intention of
causing fear and horror in its subjects, but
it thankfully wasn’t very good at this,
as the Foundation tricked it into occupying
the forms of stupid B-movie monsters.
However, after the SCP-001 upgrade, it shifted
its goals to causing happiness and contentment.
In order to do this, it took the form of SCP-999,
but without any of its anomalous effects.
Instead, it absorbed 15 agents, saying “this
is the closest anyone will be to achieving
happiness” as they suffocated within its
inescapable gelatinous mass.
SCP-2337, also known as Dr. Spanko, was a
sentient and sapient male corncrake who speaks
bizarre, nonsensical sentences at an incredibly
loud volume, destroying things with the sheer
sound of its voice.
However, thanks to the extra power imbued
by SCP-001, Dr. Spanko entered the dream realm.
He appears to people in their dreams all over
the world, causing considerable distress to
his victims by speaking to them in his trademark
deafening voice.
This has caused general anxiety and sleep
deprivation to rise across the human population.
SCP-2845, also known as The Deer, was terrifyingly
powerful before SCP-001 ever got its hands
on it.
This monster had almost unparalleled reality-warping
powers, and was only kept contained in Site-100
by tricking it into believing that the extensive
rituals used to keep it contained were actually
effective.
It’s hard to say what specific form the
001 upgrade took on SCP-2845, but we do know
that shortly after it happened, Site-100 was
lost entirely, and it became impossible to
contact any personnel who were previously
within.
And this is just a handful of the countless
anomalies that were turned into dangerous
and terrifying Super-SCPs by SCP-001, leading
what seemed like a coordinated attack not
just against the Foundation but humanity itself.
All Foundation resources were directed towards
getting this new SCP-001 situation back under
control, and that started to stretch the already-dwindling
resources of the besieged Foundation even
thinner.
Why was this happening?
Who or what was the mysterious SCP-001, and
what did it hope to achieve by making Earth’s
anomalies stronger?
To answer these questions, and have any hope
of stopping this process before it tore the
world asunder, the SCP Foundation would need
to go to deeper and darker places than they’d
ever gone before - And reckon with the secrets
in their past, present, and future.
We’d love to tell you that this is where
the horrors end.
But stay tuned.
Because, sadly, this little nightmare is only
the beginning...
Now go check out “SCP-001 - Which is the
Real 001?”
and “SCP-001 Ouroboros Cycle - The Full
Story Compilation” for more of the endless
horrors and mysteries of SCP-001!